der ist die Tablet ich feier das
irgendwas fehlt mir schade es schmeckt
so gut
geschmackloses knuspriges Brot weiß
nicht
es ist dann aber Verbraucher mein
persönliches auch heute wird ein Traum
wahr wir sind auf dem keiner
Weihnachtsmarkt
gibt einfach alles
gefrühstück wir haben nichts gegessen
heute 15 Uhr wir können uns alles was
ihr angeboten wird also
[Musik]
guck mal du hattest schon mal eine Sucht
ne aber das ist doch richtig cool aus
hier guck mal aber
das er hat einfach genommen hä oh mann
jetzt muss ich spielen was passiert du
musst gedrückt halten ne oh Mann ich
habe schon verloren
das war ein Tutorial wie man 5,3
10 €
das ist Hansas sucht ich sag's euch wie
es ist aber dann nur noch zehn
Stunden an Tankstelle früher gearbeitet
sobald du los bist danke
Mann
habe ich schon verloren was ist das denn
[Musik]
gefüllte peru-kartoffel hör ich zum
ersten Mal müssen wir probieren
[Musik]
und dann
ist da die Füllung halt drinnen
das ist jetzt Schinken Käse Mais
einmal zeigen
[Musik]
was soll ich das erinnert ansonsten
Kartoffeln es ist ja im Prinzip so dass
die Christoph Kolumbus hat die ja
mitgebracht nach Europa und das war ja
Südamerika also wir werden jetzt nicht
genau
also von daher
ist es kein deutsches Produkt
neuropäisch es wird richtig importierte
Spinat Schinken Käse weiß was du gerade
gesehen und dann Fetakäse probieren uns
immer Fetakäse Spinat
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt es riecht schon mal
sehr geil
so probier mal wir probieren es ist eine
frittierte spezielle Kartoffel welche
Kartoffel ist das Top Secret gerade
gesagt aber sie kommt das Büro gefüllt
mit Spinat und Feta übrigens
hi der heißt wo du frisch ausgebacken
ich feiere das es erinnert mich so mich
nicht eins zu eins aber es hat so ein
bisschen diesen Korean Hot Dog wie heißt
das nochmal kommen Style auch wegen dem
wegen der Soße oben drüber mit dem
Zwiebeln feier ich einzige was für
meinen Augen nicht dazu passt sind ist
ähm count unten drunter das ist jetzt
noch so ein deutsches Ding das einzige
was ich meine auch nicht zusammenpasst
aber an sich sehr lecker
das passt voll gut zusammen das passt
das schmeckt gut also für das ganze Ding
gebe ich auf jeden Fall einen neuen von
zehn beim nächsten Mal würde ich ähm
Haut weglassen ja
cool
das ist wirklich lecker wirklich
ja das schmecken anders auf zum nächsten
foodsport
[Musik]
richtig lecker ist gänsefüße ja aber
guck mal ganz ehrlich du machst so mit
Ironie ich habe eine thailändische
Freundin die Macht gänsefüße die macht
ja auch die bereitet sie auch bestimmt
lecker zu ich habe sie nur noch nie
probiert also 6 Euro also 7 Euro ja ich
weiß ist alles teurer Weihnachtsmarkt
aber es geht also es geht es ist noch
eine Grenze warum ich auch verstehe das
diese Kartoffeln jetzt 6 € gekostet es
sieht frisch aus frittiert und das ist
Handarbeit und das ist das was du so ein
bisschen hochpreisiger gemacht worden
[Musik]
ich verstehe wirklich nicht warum die
kein heller Currywurst anbieten das
ehrlich ich weiß man muss es eh drin vom
Grill Blabla und man kann ja eine kleine
Fläche machen okay das ist heller ich
will das wissen
das auch dabei
würdest du Senf dazu nimm niemals ne
würdest du mit Senf Essen ich verstehe
die Leute nicht die Senf auf ihre Wurst
ich verstehe nicht
[Musik]
dein Banane kann ich vorher noch gar
nicht
was neues
[Musik]
gibt ne man hat alles schon gesehen
richtig lecker Leute
mein neuer favorite richtig lecker boah
gibt's die Crunches bestimmt gibt es ja
auch so zu kaufen muss mal gucken wo ist
die gibt
Ikea ab zu IKEA ich muss nur Torte mit
diesem Crunchies machen wie geil ist das
denn
warum
ist noch mehr aber
richtig geil
Leute dazu zu deinem Torte kommt
richtig gut
[Musik]
einmal neutralisieren
so Langosch Klassiker du hast schon mal
gegessen
ungarische Spezialität frittiertes
frittierter Teig
aber du hast jetzt mal gezeigt
irgendeine Kirmes
ich liebe das
hier mit Knoblauch genommen
30 hat sich das gar nicht verändert oder
das war immer schon irgendwie gefühlt
450 oder 5 € so der Klassiker ist
natürlich jetzt Sauerrahm Knoblauch und
Käse
benutzt zwiegespalten also es ist lecker
keine Frage
etwas ne
ich glaube der Teig das schmeckt echt
süß
oder ich finde gerade
eine Nutella was die typisch ist so ich
weiß dass du meinst ich habe den Tag
erstmal ohne alles probiert es schmeckt
wirklich tendenziell eher süß einseitig
das stimmt ja irgendwie fehlt nur noch
so das gewisse Etwas an Kräuter Gewürz
irgendwas fehlt mir es ist recht recht
eintönig vom schmeckt ja aber ich finde
früher irgendwie anders
zu Hause
[Musik]
aber es ist okay es ist ein Klassiker
von mir gibt es sechs von zehn so haben
sie ich würde sagen lassen zweiter
futtern oder ich habe heute noch nicht
genug gegessen ein Ergebnis
[Musik]
wir nehmen gerne Dampfnudeln mit Vanille
und Mohn
[Musik]
ich hoffe das wurde mir gemacht also bei
Vanille ist unsere Anspruch so wie bei
den Haselnusskernen einfach andersrum
[Musik]
einmal gemacht
eine Kurve gemacht in den letzten Jahren
wie gesagt das ist verständlich das wird
alles teurer aber wir sind von 4 € auf
6,50 € innerhalb von drei Jahren glaube
ich hochgegangen
[Musik]
ich würde es vielleicht nicht so abends
vom Schlafengehen essen oder du nimmst
dir so eine Tablette dann weiß ich
glaube davon ein bisschen so brennen
wenn das abends ist ganz ehrlich weißt
du was schmeckt ein Brötchen da hinten
drauf
[Musik]
so richtig in die Vanillesoße rein tun
das sollte das schon aufsaugen ne
so essen jetzt mal ganz ehrlich Ding ist
einfach neutral enttäuscht mich ein
bisschen es schmeckt ultra künstlich ich
glaube wenn der Herstellung kann man
auch für den Preis eine gute Vanillesoße
machen
aber auch der Teig ist so
die Leute kommen eh nur einmal und dann
sehe dich nie wieder das ist den
Anspruch ohne Spaß das stimmt also ich
will dass es niemanden hier ähm
dafür tatsächlich ein von zehn Punkten
aber das will ich niemals essen jetzt
schade drum
also man kann das wirklich gut ich
glaube man kann wirklich wenn man ein
bisschen optimiert man kriegt das gut
hin wenn man will ich bin enttäuscht ich
will es gehen egal es kann nur besser
werden so ich neutralisiert nur noch
meine Geschmackssinne und dann geht's
auf zum nächsten Spot der wird auf jeden
Fall besser
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich ich war mit den Händen
meine Hände sind sauber und desinfiziert
das ist so der Klassiker ne also meine
Hände gerade gefragt der Bestseller ist
Reibekuchen mit Knoblauchsoße und danach
kommt Apfelmus
glaube ich aber ich nehme jetzt einfach
mal die Knoblauchsoße dazu eigentlich
nur dieses Reibekuchen mit Apfel es
schmeckt so gut so eine geile Kombi
vergisst Apfelmus so eine geile Komi
dieses
und gar nicht zu fettig das Roadster
frittiert ja aber es ist nicht so
labbrig und fettig sondern total lecker
und frisch das hat schon ein bisschen
Fräsen Pommes echt lecker
[Musik]
ich Liebster wenn man zuschauen kann das
ist feier ich hier bei den baumstriezeln
[Musik]
Überraschung für dich du musst hier
reingucken
Hunde
[Musik]
sorry
und Topf also das ist immer geben hier
ja aber es ist creme essen
okay
man konnte auch Nutella dazu sehen
Hallo Pizza
bestellen soll aber trotzdem 9 von 10
Punkte ich bin so lecker kann man immer
mal machen
Euro bin ich auch ein bisschen
hochpreisig
zubereitet darf man nicht vergessen aber
dennoch also dafür dass es wirklich nur
zum Zucker ist das niedrigste für 6 €
schon zack Zacken
es passieren noch Wunder
danke schön danke schön
[Musik]
wir haben gewonnen
Videos
Abonnent meines Kanal
[Musik]
was ist denn der Klassiker Knoblauch
Knoblauch
[Musik]
Sauce Holland
stimmt so
danke euch
[Musik]
wir haben insgesamt 13 50 für eine
Portion Champignons und eine Portion
Blumenkohl bezahlt ich muss sagen die
Marge ist bestimmt sehr gut
dann können wir zusammen mixen er wollte
das
wirklich durchgeschafft
und ich mag keine Champignons also ich
finde das gar nicht probieren
was soll ich sagen Leute Champignons auf
der Kirmes geht immer geht immer
schmeckt immer lecker dann muss ich mal
probieren
ah das ist nicht zu italienische man
schmeckt ganz klar raus ne dass diese
Sauce Hollandaise wahrscheinlich aus dem
Tetrapack ist ich glaube die werden
sogar dafür stellen die da so auf und es
schmeckt dein künstlich ne selbstgemacht
das schmeckt ganz anders
bist
trotzdem
so den Einkaufspreis
ich weiß nicht was kostet
350 oder sowas ich weiß ich weiß es ist
das jetzt hier
viele kleine hier muss ich sagen also
für den Preis bin ich ein bisschen
enttäuscht so von der Menge her
fünf große oder oder zehn kleine hast
weißt du guck mal wenn wir Bubble Balls
verkaufen ne und die sind manchmal weil
das ist ja auch ein Hefeteig manchmal
sind ihm dann gehen wir auch sechs statt
fünf
kleinen
[Musik]
alleine
immer lecker da kann man eine solide
volle Punktzahl geben aber preislich
muss ich sagen klar man muss gucken wo
man bleiben Miete ist teuer alles ist
teurer geworden aber das ist immer schon
eine gute Nase drin
bleiben können
aber preislich würde ich sagen ja nein
stell dir mal vor Mutter Vater und zwei
Kinder jeder will sich noch Champignons
gönnen wir sind 25 €, das ist nicht
wenig also gönnt man sich nicht mal eben
so ne aber ich würde sagen wir können
uns das jetzt noch und weiter geht's zum
nächsten Spot jetzt
[Musik]
spielen zusammen oder nacheinander
irgendwie ein Klassiker im Winter
auch Zusatz
also ich muss sagen die haben ein
bisschen Schwindsucht sind eigentlich
sind die ein bisschen dicker die sind
sehr also ich sehe jetzt schon dass
dieser knusprig sind so einmal
reindippen in die Nutella
hey sorry
[Musik]
die sind gar nicht so ultra knusprig
knusprig also Crunch ist gut aber Sie
sollten noch innen ein bisschen fluffy
sein und das fehlt dir einfach
so geschmackloses knuspriges Brot weiß
ich nicht schmecken wirklich ein
bisschen lieblos leider da fehlt einfach
sehr eintönig bei so einem geiler
frittierter Teig mit so es ist einfach
so ein bisschen
eintönig ja schade drum ein kleiner Flop
gewesen voller Fell eins von zehn
[Musik]
weiter geht lass uns weitergehen also
nach Tag es schmeckt wie Kaugummi kennt
ihr von uns alle Türken unter euch
kennen das mit Zimtzucker und das
traurig ein reiner zu Russland gewesen
das war jetzt nie wieder verkauft noch
das und das und dann spezialisiert auf
zu
großartig sind ja auch selber Kaffee
haben aber ist auf jeden Fall
verbesserungswürdig finde wenn man jetzt
noch jahrelang hier dann haben möchte
muss man das auf jeden Fall verbessern
mit bitte
ja okay ja es passt ein Meter
[Musik]
ein Meter Crêpes
was
Zentimeter
lang ja aber sie fühlte sich voll
austauschig
war richtig süß die war richtig süß so
viel Geld gegeben
wollen
ein bisschen geschmolzen nicht ganz ne
aber es geht auch irgendwie zu schnell
dass man glaube ich hätte durch gucken
können
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
war glaube ich cooler gewesen war die
falsche Wahl von uns aber an sich kann
man machen ist lecker wieso nicht wie
teuer war das 6 € war auch gefühlt vor
drei Jahren 4 € dafür 50 ne aber hier
sind vier buenos drinne also im
februinos im dünnen kreppmantel kann man
machen
wir gönnen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen als wir hier
reinspaziert sind haben wir direkt ein
paar Leute mit dieser riesen
kartoffeltornado gesehen und ich habe
die ganze Bock drauf haben sie gar nicht
Paprika Pulver und Topf genommen
ich vergeben von zehn zehn mein
persönlich
in einer Portion Pommes die gerade sind
eingeriffelt hast das was Besonderes das
schmeckt genauso wie dieser besondere
Moment Moment
noch alleine
ich bin heb richtig happy aber ich
brauche noch diese Ketchup oder so okay
genau
[Musik]
alle beschweren sich über den Preis von
gebrannte Mandeln und doch kauft man sie
sich jedes Jahr wieder aufs Neue ich
muss sagen
[Musik]
mittlerweile macht die jeder selber zu
Hause
geholt Weihnachtsmarkt perfekt die sind
immer viel zu knusprig wir sind viel zu
knackig
gerade
nach unten können
tut immer wieder weh man kaufte sich
immer wieder aufs Neue geht auch einfach
geht auch selber zu Hause ja es gibt
vieles selber zu Hause aber der Spaß
sollte nicht zu kurz kommen und die die
gönnung einfach zwischendurch auch nicht
die sind wirklich ein bisschen hart ist
immer schade aber es ist okay es ist
trotzdem okay
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video wir
hoffen euch gefallen macht beim
Gewinnspiel
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten
Video ob wir sowas noch mal machen
sollen genau
ein bisschen vertragen also bis dann
[Musik]